[Music]
resident evil has changed a lot of the
years slowly losing its classic Resident
Evil feel probably because it's hero
status suplexing zombies and punching
the occasional border in half well
resident evil 7 is a celebration of
classic resident evil through a
first-person perspective making the game
feel old and new at the same time we've
played around a third of the game and
it's still giving me nightmares now
here's nine things that scare the pants
off us and remember this is only a small
portion of the game Capcom have kept the
story pretty close to their chests and
even playing the press demonstration
we've skipped past story elements and
been left a little uncertain but what we
do know is the Beca family the first
member you'll get to know personally is
the head of the household Jack Baker you
know you may escape the dining table but
Jack and his trusty shovel are slowly on
your case Jack doesn't run but he's dead
meanders after you causing your hat to
risk as he rattles off one liners from
across the room just slip up before
dinner was done be sure to learn your
surroundings and not back yourself into
a corner because Jack's Reach is longer
than you think also he's happy to trash
his own house to make you empty your
bowels be it at the dining table
or even do an entire wall at least the
nemesis from resident evil 3 was kind
enough to use a window after meeting a
very nice policeman you obtain a weapon
but Jack sphere seem to have been built
by Skynet as he's impervious to bullets
that's gonna not gonna work the way you
think it will which means your
surroundings must be used during boss
fights but even using a flaming car in a
scrap of Jack only seems to hurt his
feelings oh boy now look what you've
done [ __ ] speaking of the
environment the haunted house that the
Baker's living is a remarkably well made
setting beginning with the dilapidated
aboard you've probably played in the
demo but you quickly realize the setting
is much wider and almost like a rabbit
warren some areas even feel like the
original mansion from the first Resident
Evil game classic puzzles make a return
alongside locked doors which needs
certain keys to open instead of using
keys of armor like in the good old days
you now find animal and insect themed
doors which usually have an animal
impaled on the woodwork for decorative
purposes of course the only enemy type
apart from the Baker family we've
encountered in our playthrough where the
molded slow lumbering oozing
monstrosities seem to have replaced the
typical zombies found in re games but
they do share a resemblance to many
fabled enemies Chris and Leon her fist
in the past you know what I mean the
bloody regenerators from Resident Evil 4
VHS makes a dramatic comeback in 2017
what's clever about these little
beauties is that they feel like found
footage horror like The Blair Witch
Project Oh making you once again check
if you're in walking distance to the
bathroom should a bowel movement be on
the way also these tips allow the play
to go back in time and open drawers and
find objects to be used in present day
like the lockpick behind the microwave
in the beginning our demo which allows
you to open a drawer in the past and
find an ax in the present day time
travel at its best you play as Ethan
Winters who is not a highly-trained
stars member his cardio is about as
impressive as mine getting winded by the
thought of running and he's pretty
terrible with a firearm to this is very
similar to outlast where you are unable
to fight your enemies and most instead
run for your life this gives the game a
classic horror feel like the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre or hannah montana the
movie my great Baker is Jack's wife and
she's even more terrifying than her
husband mainly due to her ability to
control a swarm of insects we won't tell
you where she keeps her in sex when
they're not flying around but let's just
say she should probably get some
counseling and maybe visit a doctor
Marguerite isn't happy to have you in
her section of the Baker compound and
we'll let you know as up gloss and
personally as she can the next one is a
fascinating fright aunt Rhody a
wheelchair-bound old-age pensioner with
zero ability to move somehow pops up all
around the mansion to home her potential
Christmas number one
[Music]
creepy as hell she hasn't moved during
our play through but we all know come
January 24th she'll scare us to death
finally psv our PlayStation virtual
reality will take horror to another
level if you don't believe me find that
one friend we all have who lives with
their parents in the late 20s usually
and can afford V our luxuries try the
demo in virtual reality and then order
re 7 online and maybe pick up a box of
deluxe adult diapers too those were the
nine scariest things we've seen so far
during our time with resident evil 7 are
you convinced by the change in direction
for the series and will you be picking
it up please let us know below also do
is a favor please and press subscribe as
we really need your support i'm adam
from playstation grenade i'll see you
next time